our description of the day first John
2:15 do not love the world other things
in this world if anyone loves the world
the love of the father is not in him
Mark Twain said whenever you find
yourself on the side of the majority it
is time to pause and reflect yep
that's why I always sign my books with
Romans 12:2 be not conformed to this
world if you do what everybody else does
you're going to get the same result so
there everybody else gets but be
transformed by the renewing of your mind
learn something that's different than
the way other people think if you want a
different result than the way the
typical then the result the typical
person gets most people are broken in
debt most people have a spare bedroom
for selling may the student loans been
around so long they think it's a pet
most people think car payments are a way
of life
most people fight in their marriage
daily or weekly about money or have
given up fighting about a decade ago and
it's gotten cold
most people don't win with money most
people aren't wealthy so find out what
most people are doing and do the
opposite whatever they're doing run the
other way 70% of Americans are living
paycheck to paycheck 7 out of 10 houses
on your street have too much month left
at the end of the money you don't want
to be like them you don't want to be
like them you want to do something
different you want to be weird if
normals broke make me weird
paint me weird Color Me weird as soon as
you possibly can I want to be strange
that's why when someone tells me that
paid off their house I always tell them
they're weird people it's a compliment
around here to be called weird normals
broke I don't want be normal and be
normal at anything yuck hey guys thanks
for watching if you enjoyed this video
click the subscribe button to get the
latest content and check out these other
great clips from the show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]